en soi c'est quand même une petite
révolution petite révolution pourquoi
parce qu'en fait Apple vient d'arriver
avec ce qui semblerait être un casque de
réalité virtuelle un casque de réalité
augmentée plutôt d'ailleurs et puis même
pourquoi pas un casque de réalité mixte
mais en fait c'est bien plus que ça et
surtout ça n'est pas ça ça les lie un
casque de réalité augmentée ni un casque
de réalité virtuelle ni un casque de
réalité mixte c'est un nouveau produit
qui vient d'arriver alors vous allez
voir parce que c'est un sujet qui est
super intéressant il y a plein d'acteurs
et notamment à HTC en fer de lance qui
propose des casques de réalité virtuelle
je sais que welcome travaille beaucoup
sur la réalité augmentée réalité
virtuelle et réalité mix on en a déjà
parlé lorsque j'étais alors conférence
ou le présenter donc c'est vraiment des
sujets qui se développent depuis des
années Apple travaillait bien évidemment
dessus depuis de très nombreuses années
il vient de présenter là sont tout
premier produit un peu hybride qui
s'appelle Vision Pro le Vision Pro on va
essayer de comprendre pour qui il est
fait et surtout est-ce qu'on va
réellement d'avoir besoin est-ce que ce
produit est si révolutionnaire qu'Apple
veut nous le raconter et puis au final
au bout du bout est-ce qu'on va
l'acheter moi je suis persuadé que vous
allez l'acheter celui-là ou son petit
frère peut-être son petit frère mais au
bout d'un moment vous allez l'acheter et
je vais vous dire pourquoi
[Musique]
il faut qu'on situe un peu l'histoire
quand Apple lance un produit c'est pas
juste un produit histoire de montrer
qu'on est capable de faire la techno
quand Apple lance un produit c'est qu'il
maîtrise la techno c'est que le marché
est là le marché est peut-être pas
réellement mature mais en tout cas le
marché réellement présent il y a donc
une clientèle à qui vendre un produit
qui quand même relativement cher mais ça
on y vient un peu plus tard et surtout
c'est un produit abouti avec des usages
une cible une clientèle et puis bien
évidemment comme on parle d'Apple ici on
parle d'application on parle de
développeurs qui vont le prendre en main
et qui vont en faire quelque chose et ça
c'est le premier point parce que même si
tout de suite on voit pas réellement
mise à part ce que nous montre un peu
appel on a du mal des fois un peu à ce
projet les encres qu'est-ce que je vais
en faire ce truc est-ce que je vais
mettre aussi cher dans ce truc là et
bien en fait pour moi ce truc là c'est
pas ce truc là c'est une vision de
l'avenir il me semble être assez juste
peut-être pas comme ça attention je vais
vous expliquer pourquoi mais ce qui est
sûr c'est que si Apple le lance
aujourd'hui en 2023 pour une mise sur le
marché en 20 24 c'est qu'ils y croient
dur comme fer et que globalement ça va
vraiment changer beaucoup de choses et
la première chose je vous montre le
communiqué de presse média que j'ai reçu
et forcément en communiqué de presse
média monsieur Greux tu dis n'importe
quoi le communiqué de presse et il le
disent et c'est pas juste un côté un peu
effet d'annonce pour eux c'est pas un
casque c'est un ordinateur spatial
révolutionnaire on se parle donc d'un
ordinateur que vous portez sur la tête
si on regarde un peu par le passé Apple
a sorti avec le Macintosh qui a très
longtemps un ordinateur alors il a
permis de démocratiser l'ordinateur la
bureautique personnel il y a eu IBM il y
en a eu plein d'autres bref mais ils ont
fait partie de ces gens-là qui ont
permis de le démocratiser ensuite Apple
a fait partie de ceux et notamment étant
faire de lance de démocratiser ce qu'on
est aujourd'hui le smartphone Sony en
tout cas sous le nom aujourd'hui du
smartphone avec son premier iPhone il y
a eu ensuite les tablettes même si au
début on y croyait pas des masses on se
dit ouais c'est pas un smartphone avec
un grand écran en fait ça sert à rien
bah si on se rend compte que ça sert à
quelque chose donc Apple vous dit on
sort ce qu'on appelle un ordinateur
spatial révolutionnaire c'est pas pour
se marrer c'est que pour eux c'est
vraiment là où on va aller l'ordinateur
demain et puis il vous le montre une
fois de plus si vous avez regardé la
quinote vous pouvez prendre un Mac milli
par exemple pas besoin de prendre un
moniteur vous pouvez prendre uniquement
votre vision pro qui vous servira de
moniteur pour afficher le contenu dont
vous avez besoin sur lequel vous allez
travailler toute la journée toute la
journée ou presque on y revient donc
niveau 10 qui attaque de façon fluide
les contenus numériques au monde réel
tout en permettant aux utilisateurs des
présents et collectés aux personnes qui
les entourent on sait que ça c'est
vraiment un truc à faire de lance de
beaucoup faire de lance j'ai
l'impression aujourd'hui dites le moi
dans les commentaires si je me répète un
peu trop des fois je me répète trop faut
que je fasse gaffe et j'écris aucun
texte il y a pas de trompeur vous voyez
là c'est la caméra c'est vous
directement moi donc bon il y a pas de
prompteur rien n'est écrit juste une
feuille avec quelques notes bien
évidemment parce que je vais pas non
plus pour raconter n'importe quoi la
vision de Tim Co c'est plus la réalité
mixte en partant surtout dans l'usage de
réalité augmentée y croient pas
nécessairement beaucoup à la réalité
virtuelle qui enferme davantage pour lui
un produit comme ce qu'ils ont présenté
avec le Vision Pro doit permettre de
s'ouvrir au monde et de communiquer avec
le monde et pas de s'enfermer dans sa
plus petite coquille dans sa petite
bulle c'est pas l'idée de pas vous lire
le tout le communiqué de presse il est
là si vous voulez lire vous mettez une
pause vous le regardez mais c'est
surtout les les
usages ce qu'on va venir en faire pour
eux c'est de nouvelles expériences qui
vont s'ouvrir il vous le montre très
clairement si vous allez sur le site
d'Apple il vous montre quelques usages
quelques vidéos hop là regardez
notamment vous voyez là la personne est
posée ici on voit un peu les yeux
regardez puisqu'on voit un peu les yeux
ça veut dire que il est pas fermé on est
sur de la réalité mixte ça veut dire que
on va superposer ce qu'on voit au monde
réel donc on est sur de la réalité
augmentée donc plus que de la réalité
mais qu'en réalité mix c'est la
combinaison de réalité virtuelle et de
réalité augmentée on fait défiler c'est
ce qu'on voit déjà c'est le premier truc
que je vais vous montrer Apple c'est que
on vient le piloter non pas avec des
commandes mais avec ses doigts puisque
vous avez tout un ensemble de caméras
qui vont venir nApp et reconnait ce qui
se passe alors il y a un leader il y a
également des caméras troudex pour
pouvoir mesurer la profondeur et savoir
réellement ce qui se passe et analyser
notamment vos gestes pour venir piloter
vos applications en plein donc là voilà
on le voit alors on reprend là on le
prend il met son casque donc là il est
très heureux il y a un joli petit
sourire et puis surtout vous voyez donc
là on voit le monde réel tel qu'il est
grâce aux caméras que vous avez
extérieures et aux écrans avec je crois
que c'est du 26 millions de pixels un
truc comme ça bref et là vous avez
ensuite l'interface qui vient se
superposer au regard du du spectateur au
regard de l'utilisateur avec vos
applications comme on le verrait un peu
sur une une Apple watch alors myful Ness
parce qu'il faut se sentir bien vos
photos Safari pour naviguer message donc
en fait ce qu'on voit ici c'est qu'on va
venir l'utiliser pour tes usages normaux
comme vous utiliseriez votre iPhone ou
comme vous utiliseriez votre APPLE watch
donc c'est une extension en fait de ces
produits là on vous met quand même qu'à
free forme alors c'est plus popotin peut
productivité pour vous dire on peut
avoir de la productivité et ils l'ont
montré justement et ça c'est un truc qui
est intéressant pour lequel vous allez
venir le prendre parce que moi par
exemple c'est très curieux de savoir si
en tant que créatif a priori ils disent
que oui je peux passer plusieurs heures
à faire un montage à faire mes
miniatures avec le casque sur la tête
même si je suis persuadé que Apple
n'aimerais pas trop qu'on dise casse
mais plus le Vision Pro ou le Vision Pro
à vous de voir imaginez je sais pas j'ai
mon casque sur la tronche comme ça et
grâce à un clavier sans fil et grâce à
une souris sans fil et bien je peux en
même temps éditer ma vidéo directement
comme ça en bougeant la tête en voyant
mes messages là en ayant des roches là
pourquoi pas j'en sais rien et tout ça
en étant dans mon univers dans ma pièce
et on n'étant pas enfermé donc l'idée
elle est plutôt cool mais une fois de
plus est-ce que je vais réussir à le
tenir longtemps sur la tronche alors
j'ai une fois de plus ça me fait penser
vraiment au airpods max le casque
d'Apple quand ils l'ont sorti on dit ouh
là là il a plus gros il est un peu plus
lourd que que le reste des autres
casques disponible sur le marché mais
pour autant lorsque je l'ai essayé et
j'utilise énormément et bien il est
extrêmement confortable avec ce tissu
mèche ils vous ont montré toute la
fabrication qu'on peut venir retrouver
la directement attendez j'essaye de le
retrouver tac tac tac ici quand je vois
ça ça a l'air d'être un peu confort
alors après il faut l'essayer pour se
rendre compte mais j'imagine qu'ils ont
vraiment travaillé sur un produit
confort pour que un maximum de personnes
puissent venir l'utiliser très
facilement sinon ça servira à rien alors
on le voit avec un petit câble on
pourrait dire ah il faut un cap faut le
connecter à un truc non c'est juste une
batterie externe parce que au bout d'un
moment l'autonomie va flancher un petit
peu si on veut un produit qui est pas
trop lourd et qui pèse pas une tonne et
pas créer un déséquilibre au niveau de
la face avant on peut pas mettre des
batteries beaucoup trop lourdes donc
pourquoi pas au bout d'un moment sur
certains usages utilisez une batterie
externe mais de la même manière est-ce
que je me vois éditer une miniature
comme ça vous voyez ok ma souris dans ma
main donc clavier Philippe mes
miniatures sur Lightroom on peut le
faire sur Lightroom pourquoi pas on peut
le faire avec Photoshop donc je sais pas
vous posez-vous la question de votre
usage personnel qu'est-ce que vous
faites sur un ordinateur qu'est-ce que
vous faites sur une tablette sur du côté
un peu plus professionnel pour de
l'éducation pourquoi pas et est-ce que
vous vous verriez le faire directement
avec le Vision Pro sur la tête moi je
suis convaincu que c'est vraiment ça qui
est intéressant parce que si Apple une
fois de plus sur ce produit c'est qu'ils
ont réfléchi et qui savent que ça va
marcher la phrase de Tim Cook ce jour
marque le début d'une nouvelle ère pour
l'informatique j'imagine que les les HTC
et compagnie ils doivent se dire mais
ils se foutent de notre gueule nous on
travaille dessus depuis des à proposer
de la réalité augmentée de la réalité
virtuelle surtout et eux ils arrivent et
pas penser à Apple c'est une révolution
mais là où c'est intéressant et là où
effectivement il y a une côté révolution
c'est que ça ouvre vraiment cette
typologie de produits au marché de masse
je sais pas ce que vous avez vous un
produit d'acheter est-ce que vous avez
un casque HTC est-ce que vous avez un
casque de metat est-ce que vous avez un
Quest est-ce que vous jouez avec il y a
des produits d'elle également est-ce que
vous avez un casque de Dell est-ce que
vous utilisez aujourd'hui soit un casque
de réalité virtuelle notamment pour le
gaming soit un casque réalité mix alors
j'imagine que si vous regardez cette
chaîne vous êtes probablement un
passionné de technologie en tout cas un
amoureux ou un curieux curieux de
technologie fait que vous avez peut-être
déjà une expérience de réalité virtuelle
mais le commun des mortels posé la
question autour de vous je suis persuadé
qu'ils n'ont pas ce typologie de
produits donc Apple arrive en ici vient
effectivement démocratiser et emmener
cette techno au grand public avec des
usages très grand public même si vous
allez voir que le prix aujourd'hui pas
trop grand public on va aller voir en
bas regardez il démarre au tarif de 3499
dollars autant vous dire que ça va pas
être fait pour tout le monde mais ça ne
surprend pas on pourrait dire mais c'est
hyper cher pour un casque de réalité
virtuelle ou réalité augmentée une fois
de plus ce n'est pas un casque de
réalité virtuelle augmentée on a une
puce m2 à l'intérieur qu'ils ont renommé
pour les besoins d'une amie de leur puce
mais c'est une puce Apple donc c'est
vraiment un ordinateur qu'on va
retrouver à l'intérieur avec une
interface gestuelle on peut également
venir le piloter à la voix avec Siri en
plus ils ont retiré la commande et Siri
vous dites juste Siri donc vous le
pilotez très facilement comme ça en tout
cas on semble le piloter très facilement
comme ça il faut attendre de voir et de
l'avoir pour se rendre compte et ils
disent qu'il sera disponible l'année
prochaine sur Apple.com auprès des Apple
Store aux États-Unis et dans davantage
de pays plus tard l'année prochaine les
clients pourront en savoir plus essayer
et personnaliser une vision pro en
sortant dans un Apple Store un produit
comme ça il faut l'essayer sans
l'essayer un moment on va pas l'acheter
il y a d'autres trucs intéressants au
niveau du communiqué de presse c'est
qu'il le note bien cet appareil n'a pas
été autorisé tel que requis par les
règles de la Fédérale communication
commission donc c'est aux États-Unis
bien évidemment cet appareil n'est pas
et ne peut pas être proposé à la vente
ou à la location ou vendue ou louer
avant l'obtention d'une autorisation il
n'ont donc pas l'autorisation
aujourd'hui de Miss sur le marché de ce
produit donc c'est pour ça que je pense
que ça prend un petit peu de temps et
qu'aujourd'hui retrouvera pas ça c'est
la première raison et la deuxième raison
c'est qu'ils veulent emmener des
développeurs avec eux pour que lorsque
vous allez mettre quasiment 3500 dollars
donc j'imagine 4000 euros sur un produit
comme ça et bien que vous ayez un
catalogue fourni avec des usages précis
et que vous alliez pas l'acheter en
espérant que demain vous puissiez en
faire quelque chose et alors regardez
une fois de plus qu'on va pouvoir en
faire des espaces sans limite pour les
apôtres au travail et à la maison des
expériences de divertissement
captivantes regardez les films des
séries alors ils vont nous chercher ils
sont vraiment plus rien d'essayer ils
vous disent vous imaginez dans votre
environnement comme ça bien vous avez
devant un écran qui se positionne ok
j'ai mon écran pourquoi pas mon centre
d'appel enfin mon application d'appel
bref WhatsApp sur le côté pourquoi pas
mais à un moment il montre un usage qui
est assez marrant vous êtes dans un
avion et vous voulez pas être emmerdé
parce que il y a soit votre écran devant
qui marche pas ça m'est arrivé une fois
sur un voyage de 11h comme ça le centre
de divertissement qui était en panne et
bien vous mettez votre casque vous
ouvrez les frontières et vous vous
retrouvez avec un espace comme au cinéma
donc vous êtes comme ça avec la personne
à côté de vous et vous allez regarder le
film au cinoche comme ça ça peut être
marrant en fait tout cet usage
divertissement pour moi il repousse les
limites une fois de plus est-ce que ça
va pas fatiguer les yeux il faut
l'essayer une fois de plus à ce que le
confort va réellement être là si vous
êtes dans un avion le fait de venir
poser votre tête dessus est-ce que ça va
être confort parce que une fois de plus
vous regardez est-ce que ça vous voyez
derrière ça va être confort lorsque vous
allez venir vous appuyez il faut parce
que sinon il y a pas d'intérêt mais je
pense que oui il vous faut fatalement
des airpods avec parce que si vous êtes
dans un endroit où vous avez du monde à
côté de vous et bien bien que vous ayez
des haut-parleurs ici ça va déranger le
monde ils vont l'entendre alors ils vous
disent vous l'utilisez avec des airpods
ok ça me paraît très très bien le truc
que j'aurais aimé pouvoir utiliser des
airpodsmax avec avec la réduction de
bruit qui est complètement folle et là
avec un casque comme ça d'un point de
vue purement ergonomique c'est pas
possible parce que si on regarde sur la
tête de quelqu'un et de profil voyez là
les oreilles elles sont comme ça mais le
casque veut pas venir le positionner
donc ça c'est un peu quand je parle ici
du casque des airpods vous avez vraiment
cette usage là de pouvoir à la fois
communiquer avec le monde en plus il y a
un truc qui est très malin qui qui va
répondre au problème où les gens disent
non mais je veux pas être enfermé et
bien même si vous avez un moment un
petit peu enfermé et que quelqu'un
arrive et bien vous allez avoir son
visage qui va apparaître au milieu de
votre contenu donc je trouve ça assez
malin une fois de plus l'autre sujet qui
est intéressant c'est de se dire tiens
on voit ses yeux par transparence
comment est-ce qu'on peut voir les yeux
de quelqu'un par transparence alors que
la personne elle a des écrans en face et
en fait on va pas ses yeux alors ils
l'ont montré dans la présentation vous
prenez votre casque face à vous il va
venir vous mapper en trois dimensions
grâce aux caméras roweppes et grâce au
leader et donc prendre une photographie
de votre visage à un instant T et
ensuite il va venir l'animer c'est à
dire que lorsque vous êtes à une
conférence avec quelqu'un FaceTime avec
votre vision pro sur la tête et bien les
gens en face vous verrons parler vous
verrons interagir tout ça mieux que
l'avatar que propose meta puis vraiment
un personnage et que je trouve pas très
pas très humanisant en fait allemand là
c'est beaucoup plus malin alors après
avoir si c'est aussi fluide que ce
qu'ils ont montré une autre sujet qui
est intéressant c'est que comme vous
pensez voir les yeux faites vous ne
voyez pas les yeux c'est la reproduction
des yeux par rapport au moment où la
personne elle a scanner son visage donc
la personne qui arrive en face il y a un
côté un peu plus humanisant on a
l'impression d'avoir des grosses
lunettes de ski où on peut voir un peu à
travers alors qu'en fait vous voyez rien
c'est juste un écran qui vient vous
affichez ça une fois de plus si vous
remettre la Digital Crown pour jouer sur
la dans l'opacité les souvenirs bon why
not time qui devient spatial ça c'est
vraiment un truc qui m'intéresse
énormément et puis des applications ils
ont fait parler le CEO de Disney pour
Disney plus avec des expériences qui ont
l'air absolument dingue immersive donc
ça c'est vraiment hâte de le tester
alors bien évidemment ils ont nommé l'os
comme il y a Mac OS iOS iPad OS il y a
vision os après il faut le mettre d'un
point de vue purement technologique une
puce Apple des écrans micro OLED avec 23
millions de pixels dans deux écrans pour
chacun la taille d'un timbre poste ils
ont travaillé également avec zice pour
les optiques et ce qui est génial c'est
que pour les personnes qui pour
notamment atteint de myopie et bien vous
allez pouvoir avoir des optiques
spécialisés adaptés à votre vue pour
pouvoir consulter le casque parce que
bien évidemment on va pas mettre ses
lunettes sinon ça marche plus donc un
casque qui est à la fois un iPhone un
iPad une télé une Apple télé un Mac
également par mois il plusieurs
avantages qui semblent se détacher de ce
produit déjà il y a d'être assez confort
sa globalement quand on voit les images
on se dit que c'est confort et on a
envie de la mettre sur la tête vraiment
envie d'essayer ensuite sans fil sauf la
petite batterie externe ça c'est aussi
un point très très important ça me
davantage troisième avantage le fait de
le piloter comme ça directement avec les
mouvements de vos mains sans rien dedans
et à la voix grâce à Siri clavier et
souris sans fil pour venir travailler
sur la productivité ça s'intéresse
également et comme vous voyez votre
pièce vous baissez les yeux vous avez
votre cahier vos souris vous avez votre
affichage devant vous mais je vois aussi
pas mal de petites limites je me demande
parce que ils vous disent ok on a 12
millisecondes d'écart entre ce que vont
filmer les caméras c'est à dire votre
environnement est-ce que vous vous allez
voir et c'est souvent ça qui crée ce
qu'on appelle le motion sickness c'est à
dire un effet un peu de nausées moi
quand ce que j'utilise un casque de
réalité virtuelle ou même de réalité
augmentée et un moment c'est la nausée
je suis pas très bien je suis pas
confort je commence à transpirer je me
sens pas bien il faut un bon moment pour
commencer à être mieux là à priori avec
ses 12 millisecondes ils ont réussi à
solutionner ce problème de motion
sickness donc ça j'ai vraiment envie de
voir si si c'est le cas puis je me
demande vraiment si on peut vraiment
garder un casque aussi longtemps sur la
tête et est-ce que c'est souhaitable
est-ce que c'est bien au-delà du côté
physiologique pour vos yeux est-ce que
c'est souhaitable d'avoir ailleurs toute
la journée mais un bon moment de la
journée un casque sur la tête pour venir
échanger avec des gens pour des appels
en visio pour venir regarder du contenu
multimédia pour venir travailler est-ce
que c'est ce qu'il faut est-ce que ça
viendrait réellement remplacer un écran
alors aujourd'hui Apple vous le dis pas
il vous dites pas ça va venir remplacer
nos écrans professionnels soyons clairs
c'est pas le but mais malgré tout il
nous montre quand même des gens qui
travaillent avec ils nous montrent quand
même des gens qui regardent du contenu
avec ils nous montrent des gens qui font
des appels avec nous montre des gens
captent des souvenirs et qui les
regardent avec l'idée c'est quand même
de l'utiliser au maximum dans un maximum
de temps combien de temps en réalité
puis-je le supporter sur la tête d'un
point de vue physique et de deux est-ce
que d'un point de vue plus philosophique
c'est souhaitable d'abord un casque sur
la tête assez longtemps dans la journée
et ce bien évidemment sur plusieurs
jours vous voyez ça soulève plein de
questions alors je pense qu'aujourd'hui
il y a encore un peu de travail
peut-être de la part d'Apple alors pas
au niveau de la conception parce que ça
va être plutôt bien fini mais il va
falloir développer davantage de choses à
mon avis emmener plus de développeurs
pour que le produit soit hyper
accessible pour tout le monde pour tout
un chacun moi en tout cas je suis plutôt
à IP je pense que vous allez l'acheter
et je vous le dis une fois de plus pas
forcément les visions Pro version 1
parce que je reste persuadé que l'avenir
du smartphone l'avenir la technologie
passe par la miniaturisation et par le
fait de se libérer les mains donc un
smartphone c'est bien mais c'est une
contrainte on a pas envie de toujours
avoir un truc à la main si par exemple
je me déplace dans la rue j'ai pas envie
d'avoir mon smartphone pour regarder
comme ça où est-ce que je dois aller
alors je peux le faire avec mes
écouteurs ouais mais des fois c'est bien
d'avoir une flèche qui vous indique à
droite à gauche ça c'est visuel c'est
pratique donc le fait d'avoir un casque
ça me paraît bien je préférerais avoir
des lunettes plus qu'un casque mais
j'imagine que c'est là où on va tendre
il y a aujourd'hui des problématiques
physiques au niveau des produits on peut
pas faire tout tenir dans un produit
plus miniaturisé mais une fois de plus
c'est la V1 regardez le premier iPhone
regardez là où on en est aujourd'hui
alors c'est l'inverse des petits on
augmente parce qu'on veut augmenter les
tailles des écrans mais là ça va être
l'inverse on a un produit qui va être un
peu encombrant au début puis il y a que
peut-être très confortable mais qui
devrait se miniaturiser à l'avenir en
étant pratique simple qu'on peut emmener
partout avec soi en tout cas la promesse
que tant à faire ce produit les mains
libres on l'utilise tout le temps en
permanence facilement donc c'est une
nouvelle ère qui s'ouvre effectivement
là je suis totalement d'accord avec ce
que nous dit Apple c'est l'air de
l'informatique les mains libres tout sur
la tronche et alors après on peut
imaginer d'autres produits peut-être que
pour un côté plus informatique on
prendrait un casque mais pour un produit
uniquement extension j'en sais rien ou
de smartphone ou c'est un peu con mais
remplacement de smartphone on aurait des
lunettes peut-être allez savoir j'en
sais rien qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
vous est-ce que pour vous le Vision Pro
ouvre effectivement la voix à autre
chose est-ce que c'est comme le dit Tim
Cook un ordinateur spatial
révolutionnaire est-ce que c'est ça
selon vous dites le moi dans les
commentaires est-ce que vous pourriez
être intéressé au-delà du prix bien
évidemment aujourd'hui Apple on sait
très cher un ordinateur ça vaut à peu
près ce prix là donc bon c'est pas
déconnant par rapport au prix d'un
MacBook Pro ça me surprend pas du tout
ça produit en plus qui est neuf et qui
est innovant il va falloir un petit peu
rentabiliser tout ça tout le travail qui
a été fait derrière la R&D les brevets
et compagnie bref normale ou 3400 euros
3400 dollars pardon j'imagine un peu
moins peut-être 4000 euros par 4200
euros allez savoir peut-être ça me
paraît pas déconnant c'est cher mais
c'est pas déconnant pour se produire
mais est-ce que pour vous c'est l'avenir
est-ce que ça va venir gommer certaines
choses peut-être supprimer quelques
usages qu'on a avec une tablette est-ce
que ça va pas supprimer les iPad est-ce
que ça va pas venir à terme supprimer un
Mac ou en tout cas faire que et bien on
aura juste un clavier une souris et puis
pas d'écran je sais pas dites moi ce que
vous en pensez dans les commentaires et
est-ce que vous pourriez l'acheter on en
reparlera on en reparlera en tout cas en
2024 ça c'est sûr peut-être cette année
allez savoir dites parce que vous en
pensez dans les commentaires et on se
retrouve très bientôt pour continuer à
parler de tac Sandra bisous Ciao